we got a clip here where they talk about
chivalry i'm going to do a live reacts
to this i think there's some stuff here
that's great i think there's stuff here
they get wrong
let's talk about it
right here's the reality this is why
chivalry's dead and women killed it i
mean y'all could say what you want to
say man but why is a man real talk like
like feminism is here you know women are
more educated than ever before they make
their own money you know what i'm saying
and as a byproduct of them being making
their own money and becoming more
successful you get a little bit more
masculine energy you're not going for a
second heavy hit okay
this is a common mistake and i made it
the other day
so you know obviously you gotta own your
say this is a common mistake um when
peop when when guys feel like a woman is
getting very badass
they say she has a masculine energy i
said at the adam sat here the other day
and i said it i said you know i have
kind of like a i don't know what you
would call it maybe i have a little bit
of a
masculine energy that's not what i meant
that's a misspeak on my part i need to
correct that
what that means is a they're confusing a
masculine energy with a badass energy
okay
women are more badass in general now
than they used to be in the sense that
women are now in the workforce more
women have to brush shoulders with
high-powered people in high-powered
industries i worked in the tv industry
i'm brushing shoulders with all these
people make a [ __ ] ton of money you're
dealing with money right i'm negotiating
contracts i'm dealing with
i have to you know be part of that
negotiation sit in those board rooms
it's a badass energy
so i know sometimes the reason we we
jump to say masculine is because
oftentimes that was associated with men
right but it's a badass energy and it's
not necessarily tied to other behavior
that is typically
thought of as male
now the part he's right about
i'm going to continue to play the clip
but he's 100 right that chivalry is
dying and women are a big reason why
let's watch the end and then we'll get
to that part
be hitter making money by being passive
and a [ __ ] you're gonna become a little
bit more masculine right and then on
that
women are just having a little bit more
recreational sex which is fine right
cool do your thing but you can't expect
men to be traditional hold the door open
for you pay for the date yeah treat you
like a lady etc when you guys are no
longer traditional women it's [ __ ]
yeah so guys have adapted to the
situation because men haven't really
changed women
have so that part about recreational
they always throw this in not them
meaning a lot of guys in the space who
are trying to get to the bottom of
what's going on something's changed
women have changed
they're trying to get to you know some
people feel men are being abused in the
situation now some people feel women are
being abused everyone's talking over
each other a lot of the time i don't
want to do that i want to talk with
people
recreational sex women having more
recreational sex
that's not
first of all it's not badass it's not
it's not doing women any favors it's not
doing men it's not good it's not good i
told you don't put the goods out there
it's not good ladies you're not
increasing your value by being [ __ ]
you're not i think they would probably
agree with me on that
but
recreational sex and whether or not you
have recreational safety that's not tied
to
you know being a badass that's a
separate issue like i consider myself a
badass woman you may agree you may
disagree i'm a badass woman in my mind
because i stand up for what i believe in
because i can sit at this table i can go
toe-to-toe with someone who disagrees
because i did have a focus on career but
i also have a focus on family my baby
comes first i know where my priorities
are i'm loyal i'm faithful i'm honest
i'm gonna tell you how i really feel
that's what makes me a badass woman i
didn't have recreational sex so don't
make it like
this this new wave of women that are
hyper feminists and are out there and
are like oh i can spread my legs and
it's so empowering i can be just like a
shitty man and it's apparent like there
don't group them in with me don't group
them in with other badass women that may
be badass in the boardroom
but aren't having recreational that's
not what it's about okay so that stuff
just gets conflated i know it's hard to
follow but all this stuff gets conflated
these are really separate issues
oftentimes
now let me say something to the ladies
though they're right
they're right about chivalry chivalry is
dying
it's dying if not dead
right
women you can't say to guys
i want you i want a gentleman i want a
gentleman and then when that guy goes to
offer to pay for dinner or pay for
dinner or open your door for you
you're suddenly mad you're like why is
he doing that for me i'm a woman i i can
i'm perfectly capable of doing it myself
make up your mind he knows you're
capable of doing it yourself if you have
arms you're capable of pulling the door
he that's not why he's doing it he's
doing it to be a gentleman so you can't
[ __ ] about him being a gentleman and
also say you want a gentleman do you
want a gentleman or not make up your
mind he's right
so now you have a whole bunch of
feminists walking around out there i
hate that word too because you know
women women say oh i'm a feminist and i
don't even know what that means anymore
i don't even know what that means what
does that mean at one time that meant at
one time feminists were pro-life
at one time feminists meant that you
wanted female empowerment it's not
empowering to be a [ __ ] now that's the
new feminism [ __ ] that's not
empowering it's embarrassing you're
embarrassing the whole gender when you
do that you are so make up your mind if
you want a gentleman you got to let him
be a gentleman you can't make that an
opportunity to have a moment and have a
conversation with yourself about
feminism and then go open the door for
yourself and then call your friend when
you get home and say he didn't even open
my car door
because you know you do it
so they're right about that
so i think what happens in these
conversations and i love that they're
having these conversations i do i love
it i think these are important
conversations that need to be had
i think what's missing for these for me
in a lot of these conversations is the
nuance of it right it's like if you're
badass somehow you're also sleeping
around you're you're the new feminist
you're that person who who wants to
complain about having your doors no
no that's not that's your that's like
putting women in a box
you can't do that
you can't do that because that ignores
all the badass women in the boardrooms
who do like to have a gentleman and do
let that gentleman open the door and
aren't sleeping around and are
prioritizing their family
it's just not so black and white this is
a gray space and what you have is people
talking black and white over each other
getting insulted demeaning each other
condescending
no
you got to look at the gray if you want
to fix what's broken and let me tell you
shit's broken right in the dating arena
shit's broken
men feel disrespected women feel
disrespected women don't trust men men
don't trust women if you want to fix
that
stop looking at the area like it's black
and white and start talking to the gray
there's a lot of gray out there if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here